build it draw it plan
Vsauce this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is speedy
yoga berlin-based Korean artist jung
woon creates incredible thread
installations audiences are allowed to
roam within the rooms where the colored
thread is illuminated by UV lights by
giving the room a 3-dimensional sense
it's as though the viewers have entered
a virtual blueprint jaunty her which
creates anamorphic sculptures that are
made by scanned objects distorted
digitally and then fabricated but once
the sculpture is placed in front of a
cylindrical mirror the reflection
reveals the original image other works
include a pixelated or sliced human
forms that are only viewable from
certain angles Hurwitz a scientist at
heart claims that his art is a way of
expressing calculations visually Amos
Reed in Los oviya from Royal College of
Art in London have built a belt-driven
mobile espresso bar that they call Bella
presto the bike uses a carbon belt drive
system to power the bike and a
custom-made coffee grinder that with
five seconds of pedaling will grind
enough coffee for a double shot they
currently use a camp stove to heat the
water and steam to power the espresso
machine but are working on a way to
create their own fuel using coffee
grounds Troy Maurice Bennett creates art
with toast these portraits are created
with thousands of pieces of bread
toasted to different tones to create
highlights and lowlights they're very
large and usually displayed as
billboards or in public spaces because
the best view is gained from being at a
good distance away from street artists
oak Oak uses stencils and paint to
create works of art around crumbling
buildings cracks in the ground and
pretty much anywhere in anything he can
create interesting and often humorous
artwork including this cinder block
screen painting or storm from the x-men
shooting wall crack light ink bolts and
now for the art of scum dance the group
art show that celebrates famous movie
villains
designer Matteo of creative studio age
57 made these minimalist poster designs
of popular movies where the plot is
condensed into their most basic forms
including Lord of the Rings et The
Shining and The Matrix plyatt here's a
cover of the animals as leader song CAFO
by Chino M and his cello
French beatboxer elem keeps up with this
metronome as it increases in speed the
music video for katashi my shoe go toka
motto is multi-layered stop-motion
journey
ah
finally the video for better man than he
was directed and edited by Adam Powell
using MRI scans faking was magic
I see the pain
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at the Vsauce to
Facebook page and I'm witness violence
after-school detention chains and a
pension crisis along with arthritis and
crime it's all is in the garbage you
drop fester the black depth we've access
from what wheelchair I don't even
brought my real hair I've got a wing
upon the yes though Uncle Fester use the
point sixty school with dr. laser
nothing but ice is far back
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to your creations and as
always thanks for watching
you